Jam c'est un jeu, et en fait on envoie des comédiens
sur un lieu qu'ils ne connaissent pas et on a
une journée pour l'écrire et faire tourner un sketch.
Making Jam
L' aventure commence à Saint-Mandé
On aurait pu trouver plus ... heu ...
plus dangereux comme bled, je me demande bien où on va quand meme
c'est pareil j'étais là il y a deux secondes j'étais en train de le dire
En gros je savais tout
Est ce que vous savez ou on va? Oui
Là ça fait 30 minutes qu'on roule
Et Ken et Jérôme savent toujours pas où ils vont.. Enfin Jérôme il...
Moi je sais un peu parce que Julfou a bourdé tout à l'heure donc
je vais éviter de bourder et ne rien dire.
C'est ce qui me fait marrer aussi dans Jam
c'est ce côté un peu jeu
un peu Fort-Boyard
Tu fais un peu ton Frédéric Lopez
On est partis vers le parc Astérix
et donc au bout d'un moment au bout de très longtemps d'ailleurs Kyan a fini par comprendre
avec des panneaux finalement avec Asterix dessus
Alors Kyan
as-tu des indices?
On est passé devant 3 indices sans que tu le voies
Alors Kyan
Huuuuuuuum
Huuuuuum
C 'est Walibi
Oui
toute l'equipe était réunie et Julien
nous a
fait un petit
Brief
Il nous a expliqué ce qui allait se passer
Valérie tu nous la fais à l'américaine on est sur le tournage du premier Jam
Voila il y a toute l'equipe en gros
et on a du coup une journée pour faire un Sketch
c'est le concept
ce soir on doit repartir avec des images OK
et des vannes, peut être , ça serait bien, on a ici les parains
On a Kyan Khojandi, on a Adrien Ménielle, on a Vincent Tirel, on a La Ferme Jérôme, Jérôme Niel
Je serais un petit peu les maître des clés, le maître des jeux , le passe partout, le Denis Brogniart
c'est pas écrit hein je vous rassure
les gars je vous rappelle les règles voila ce soir on repart avec un sketch
j'ai fait la liste de 3 handicaps tout à l'heure bon on sera obligé de changer de caser etc
bon écoutez c'est nikel, on se découvre le décor?
ON VA DÉCOUVRIR LE DÉCOR !!
C'était ouf quoi on etait tous ensemble. 'Fin apres moi jai pas du tout participé à ce projet.
Je suis venu parce qu'ils tournaient les interviews du coup.
Tourner au parc Asterix c'etait vraiment cool et surtout qu'ils ont été vraiment géniaux parce qu'en gros ils ont
des maisons hantées qu'ils utilisent que pour Halloween
donc hors période Halloween en gros ben on peut tourner d'dans.
Oh putain ! Oh ouais !
A l'époque y'avait l'épicerie de mon père, ça n'a presque pas changé.
Et là on est tout seul dans le parc, ça ouvre dans quelques minutes
Et on va tourner dans un décor particulier.
On découvre enfin les vrais lieux, une espèce de grange, pleine de débris humains
premier décor possible on a deux décors possible
Ça sent le caprice des dieux mon gars.
Sachant que ici pour moi, on peut clairement faire une prison
ça ça se referme
et très vite on peut avoir une impression de prison
tu vois mon oncle Joe
le tonton Joe le taulards
ça se passe là
lls vont chez lui et c'est ici quoi bon c 'est le bordel tu fais pas gaffe
voila donc
donc du coup là bas il y a la chaise éléctrique, mec vas-y assieds-toi je t'en prie et tout
voila donc tu filmeras pas ça parce que il a pas ri donc euh, le silence apres le truc
Le bruit est nikel
je voudrais bien un plan sur ça
et t'sais un oeil comme ça
juste le mec apres il a une planche en bois sur lui et tout tombe
salut
Il regarde tout le temps à travers
Julien nous a montré deux trois accessoires qui étaitent, étalés sur le sol il y'avait vraiment de tout des flingues des katana
accessoires les gars
accessoire possible
gunfight mon pote
1er handicap les gars
objet à placer pas facile
un YO-YO
Ok nikel sa peut carrement etre un des 4 persos qui fait tout le temps du YO-YO
t'sais on l'a pas placé pendant dans le sketch et à la fin
t'es déjà costumière, pas mal. Impeccable
bon voila faut farfouiller allez y
Normalement, y'a de quoi
de quoi fouiller de quoi faire du douchebag ya de quoi faire du nerds ya de quoi faire des jeun's
dans le 1er handicap YO-YO
dans le 1er handicaps caser le YO-YO
2eme handicap
une réplique à caser j'ai demandé à des gens sur internet de proposer
Au monde entier, t'as demandé au monde entier
et donc on a séléctionné
La réplique de MrsStitchette qui a proposé "Parceque tu savais pas qu'il savait que tu savais et moi non plus"
Wo, alors on la refait
Parceque tu savais pas qu'il savait que tu savais et moi non plus
Putain j'ai l'impression que ça va écrire le sketch ça tellement c'est précis
Deja c'est compliqué, ça impose une situation compliqué
dernier handicap l'un des personnages a un frère jumeaux ou un frère jumelle
Ah c'est bien sa
là vous avez quasiment toutes les clefs on peut la dernière étape c'est d'aller voir Dorian
qui a des péruques qui a les accessoires etc...
donc la on a tout les produits sillicone et compagnies
donc en gros on a du sillicone t'as des lentilles aussi ? C'est ça, ta des dents aussi du coup Ouai!
ta des dents aussi du coup Ouai!
si on veux
Vampire, on peut faire des dents
un max de perruques un max de barbiches
c'est les péruques du Palmashow fait gaffe mec y'a y'a une nuque longue regarde regarde
Bah dit dont Gaspard
ça rend ou pas ?
et puis une fois qu'on a découvert les décors, les maquillages, les costumes,
les accessoires , maintenant il faut écrire un sketch
Et si on veut tous jouer en même temps
situation ils sont tous encore ensemble tsais il essaye de prendre des décisions
attends mais toi t'es vraiment bizarre
Comme rôle aussi il peut y avoir l'espèce de
gros perso baroudeur et qui pourrait mourir direct quoi
tu sais PA!
très vite on a eu plein d'idées on a commencé tout de suite à s'amuser
on était plutôt dans une dynamique comique
si vous voulez vous en sortir vous feriez mieux de m'écout...Ha
si vous comptez sortir d'ici vivant
je vous conseille de m'écouter
la on tourne les fond vert
pour la présentation des joueurs de JAM
Mais y'a une règle, c'est que les tueurs n'ont pas le droit de se tuer entre eux
Genre ça commence, ils se racontent leurs anecdotes de tueurs
"Oh putain, l'autre jour..."
Comme ça on profites des décors
T'sais c'est un peu comme: "Je t'ai jamais vu avec une meuf.", "Je t'ai jamais vu buter un mec moi."
J'ai buté des mecs, mais c'était en colo
J'ai tué un mec mais c'était en colo, c'était... C'était à la Baule.
On a eu très vite pleins de pistes de pleins de sketches
Après, le plus dur, ça a été de choisir quelles pistes on allait vraiment creuser.
Et quelles pistes on allait mettre de coté
On écoute et on a pas envie de décider. On a pas envie de dire: "Nan, ta vanne elle est moins bien."
Ou "Ça c'est moins bien"
En fait, le problème, c'est qu'on a toujours envie de trouver une meilleure idée...
...et du coup on avance jamais quoi.
Si le sketch, tu le mets et que tu dit pas y'a JAM et tout
Et qu'y'a des gens qui fassent: "Putain, c'est un bon sketch
C'est ça en fait dans ma tête.
Je lui dit hors JAM, c'est un bon sketch
Mais c'est pas fait pour être poussé comme ça.
Oui mais, l'idée, c'est que c'est pas vraiment décrire un truc et de le tourner
-...mais plus d'un point de vue
-Dans tout les cas, on a pas trop le temps
on va être obligé de pendant qu'on tourne
de faire des propositions
Y'a des petits stress parce qu'on se dit qu'il faut réussir à...
Etablir le
le sketch pour que ça ressemble à quelque chose
Le sketch qui ne s'est jamais fait JAM
le projet maudit de Julien Josselin.
Très vite tu te rends compte que quatres heures sont passés
et que t'es en retard et que t'a pas...
Que t'as huit mille idées mais que t'en as pas une sur laquelle tout le monde est d'accord.
Ça serait bien qu'on reparte d'ici
dans dix minutes avec une situation qui nous plaît.
On a dit: "On doit faire un truc de film d'horreur"
On a tous eu pleins d'idées de gags genre à la "Hot Shot"
machin...etc
Et après on s'est dit:
"On va pas faire ça et on va faire autre chose"
et on a que trouvé des trucs où on avait moins d'idées
et quand même, le principe du truc c'est:
"On a une idée. On a tous pleins d'idées."
Ca se trouve, on a un décor... on est trop dedans
et on a pas le décalage
Le but du jeu c'est quand même d'aller...
d'aller insister sur les clichés ou quoi. Nan ?
Je viens de me rappeler du flip. C'est: On peut plus vanner sur le coté fiction
Y'a jamais personne qu'a tranché pour dire:
"Bon, là c'est bon, faut faire ça parce que sinon on avancera jamais"
Est-ce qu'on insite sur cette idée vu que...
-Nan nan, oui oui !
-Nan, je pense pas. Je pense pas.
Ah nan mais voilà.
JAM, c'est aussi ça:
On est allés manger. On a continué de discuter en mangeant.
Bon, par contre, sur l'idée
dont on avait parlé pas mal à André qui était:
la pose clope de serial-killer
les idées les plus simples qu'on a eues
jusqu'à présent
c'est celles là qu'on doit choisir
Le jumeau pour l'explication du: il tombe face à moi
Y'a mieux
Ouais, que ce soit pas juste une vanne justement
J'étais pas au courant
que tu savais que j'étais au courant pour ton histoire.
On est partis là dessus et on l'a combiné avec d'autres idées qu'on avait eues...
qui étaient pas forcément liées
Et en fait, on a eu l'idée
d'utiliser ce dialogue pour faire le lien entre toutes les idées qu'on avait eues
On partirait sur "killer nul" enfin..."bon"
"Killer nul"
Donc au début ça commence comme ça:
Tu vois une victime faire:
C'est pas mal pour introduire les deux premiers.
Ahhh, c'est pas commode !
A chaque fois, le killer explique ses bonnes anecdotes
et le mauvais il fait: "Ouais, moi je l'ai fait avec la griffe"
Il fait que des mauvais trucs
ouais c'est nul ouais
Moi j'arrive pas...toi t'as des bonnes punchlines.
Moi j'arrive pas. Tu vois. Faudrait que ça fasse echo
Tu peux faire pleins d'illustr-
Tu peux faire genre j'en ai testé plusieurs
T'as plein de trucs vraiment en fait qui marchent
Ah ouais c'est pas mal.
Justement, j'ai du mal, vraiment, à trouver le...
J'ai pas de punchlines. J'en ai essayé vachement pourtant.
mise en situation
"Alors les ptits lou, salut les ptits clous !
C'est..." Ah non c'est pas ça
Et Kyan, il dit: "Nan ça c'est pas bon"
Moi j'ai du mal avec les phrases d'accroches
Coucou ! Qui c'est que v'la ?
Paf, ça sort du placard et pourtant je suis
pas homosexuel
-Ah ou sinon
En fait, la victime, elle est arrivée au début
En fait, je cherche mon personnage
Mais je pense que c'est pas drôle de le
faire un peu genre
"Ouais tu vois, faut que tu fasses gaffe
Faut que tu prennes soin de toi"
Je vais arriver genre plus:
"En fait, tu vois, faut que tu fasses à toi, à ta santé.
Faut que tu prennes des vitamines"
Si, à un moment donné, l'écriture est drôle et
que le personnage est marrant à écouter
C'est ça qu'est intéressant. Tu vois ?
J'ai jamais flippé
en me disant: On va pas y arriver
Parce que, pour moi, le principe de l'exercice
C'était d'être toujours dans...
dans l'improvisation et la démerde quoi.
On commence à essayer de s'activer
On se rend compte qu'on est vraiment en retard en fait.
Et que Jérome doit partir dans... une heure, un truc comme ça.
Est-ce qu'on va refaire les répliques de Kyan
dans la conversation, sans moi ?
Pour qu'il ait le temps d'en refaire si il veut. Tu vois ?
Dans la première conversation, on est à trois.
C'est pour ça que je te dis on triche
pour que j'aie le temps de tout faire
Est-ce que, après, vous allez refaire
comme si j'étais là
mais en gros il te regardera, toi tu le regarderas
Oui, je mets ton tee-shirt
Bah oui parce que moi si je me casse à cinq heure...
Ouais ouais, ok
-On commence même par les punchlines
-Ouais
un quart d'heure pour les punchlines
Il est quelle heure ? Il est quinze
tu parts dans trois quarts d'heures
C'est très très très serré.
Là, Jérome, il part dans cinquante minutes.
On a rien tourné encore.
C'était tellement écrit à un moment qu'on
on a peut-être perdu un peu l'envie
l'envie parce qu'on avait l'impression d'avoir déja fait
de l'avoir déja fini.
Parce qu'on avait déja ri sur les blagues.
Jusqu'à ce que AK et...
et Vincent trouvent, heureusement, une meilleure fin
que celle qu'on avait
Et ouais mon pote
Moi je les prends par surprise
C'est ça ma technique.
Ouais, j'avoue, je l'ai pas vu venir
Et ouais, tu l'as pas vu venir
parce que tu savais pas qu'il savait que tu savais
ah très bien, oui
devoir trouver des idées rapidement
et tout
'fin je trouvais ça vraiment stimulant
Un sur un. Première
La première à quatre heure
OK
Quand tu veux Jérome
Et...
Action !
Bonjour
Je viens pour le meurtre
Salut bande de salopes !
Eh eh eh. Les simpsons
Ça commence à bien sortir quand même un peu
et ouvre-la un peu plus sec
-Je dis la phrase longue ?
Ouais
Genre: "Eh vous allez bien voir quand je vais vous tuer"
Alors là, vous êtes bien surpris mais
après ça vous allez voir, vous allez etre encore plus surpris
Parce qu'après, je vais vous découper la tête.
Ah ah ! Tu ne croyais pas que j'étais là, hein ?
Oh, ça nan ! Tu croyais pas
Parce que j'étais juste derriere
Alors que tu t'y attendais absolument pas
Ce soir, je vais te tuer, mon pote !
Regarde ce que je sais faire avec mon couteau
Mesdames et messieurs, bonsoir
et bienvenue dans le journal de 20h
Et tu pourra dire: "Vous êtes fatigués"
Vous êtes fatigués ?
Donc on s'active, on tourne le sketch
et on va au plus vite qu'on peut
tout en s'amusant
OK. Ensuite:
"moi j'y arrive pas, ces trucs là. J'ai vraiment de mal avec les punchlines"
Et Kyan, il fait:
"Ouais nan mais c'est pas grave. Ça se travaille.
Ce qui est important, aussi,  c'est la mise en scène tu vois"
Faudra pas oublier "ça se travaille"
Toi tu reviens et tu fait
"ohh" genre t'es là, ty crois pas trop. Tu vois ?
C'est un peu l'effet qu'y a dans les
Scream. Y'a toujours un double.
Ils ont toujours un double
"Putain, mais il est toujours partout lui
comment ça se fait ?"
Et... Action !
On a fini par faire un sketch scénarisé
en une journée, en, fait.
Alors que le concept de JAM pour moi
C'est vraiment:
On a une situation
on tourne
et après on s'amuse
on rajoute des vannes
On était déjà très proche d'un truc très abouti
a mon avis, y'a pas énormément de choses
à améliorer
Je pense que maintenant, Julien a une idée
à peu près de ce qu'il veut faire pour le prochain
Moi j'imposerais plus de choses.
Qu'il y ait des rails, à prendre.
Et là dessus, on va pouvoir
s'éclater
Si y'a des gens qui kiffent
je pense qu'on fera un JAM épisode deux
Et ça ressemblera tellement pas au premier en fait.
Si on veut surveiller genre: il filme et ...
-Ah ouais, peut être. Quand même
-Plus victorieux
Si vous comptez sortir d'ici vivant,
je vous conseille de m'écou...
-Ahhhhhh *ensemble*
Vous avez regardé JAM 1
et je vous en remercie
Coupé !
Vincent Tirel: Cascadeur
en streaming
Avec un vieux décalage dégueulasse
streaming mais dégueulasse.